The connection between common-sense reasoning and human cognition is both very
strong and not yet fully understood. Let us suppose that I were to
ask you to go find the weather outside. You would not jump out of the window.
Why not? You would use common sense reasoning to know that jumping out of
the window to find the weather is not a good idea. But what is it
that tells you not to jump out of the window? You use the notion of goals.
The notion of context to decide what not to do and what to do.
We use similar notion of context in order to do natural language understanding.
We could use context to disambiguate between various meanings of take.
Can we context also to decide on what would be a good source of plan. So
far we have been talking about common sense inferences about physical actions,
what about the social world? You and I also make common sense inferences about
the social world around us. One possibility is that you and
I have a flurry of mind, this is actually called the flurry of mind theory.
You and I as cognitive agents, ascribe goals, beliefs, desires to each other.
And it's the theory of mind that allows us to make inferences about each other,
including common sensical inferences.